welcome welcome to Yale and we look
forward to your your comments on this
interesting space in which you have done
a lot of work thank you your side suit
feedback but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go through a batch of slides and
then I'll pause I'll ask for questions
and you know hopefully hopefully you're
still out there because right now I'm
sitting in my office talking to a blank
screen with no feedback so every once in
a while I'll just turn over to you to
make sure you're still there and things
are working fine okay
I want to talk about this notion of
inclusive wealth and in general this is
I've done a lot of work on ecosystem
services and value ecosystem services
and integrating ecology economics but
the inclusive wealth framework is is an
interesting one for thinking more about
the dynamics of systems and do we are we
on a sustainable development pathway or
trajectory so let me launch in and as I
said I'm happy to have questions I'll
try to pause at sort of reasonable
intervals so you can you can fire away
okay so to me the sustainable
development question really is can we
are are we on a global socio ecological
system is that on a trajectory that we
can maintain or enhance human wellbeing
over the long term okay so I'm gonna
take a very anthropocentric view so this
is from the viewpoint of humanity can we
sustain he will well-being now you could
modify this approach and say you know
can we maintain biodiversity or from
other species point of view clearly if
we don't maintain ecosystems and
biodiversity that has impacts on human
wellbeing so I'm going to be including a
lot of what happens in nature through
its impacts to how it affects people
so that taking seriously the notion of
ecosystem services okay so what I'm
gonna do here just as Pavan suggested I
want to discuss a framework and really
the inclusive wealth framework for
thinking about whether we're moving in
the right direction or the wrong
direction if we want if we care about
sustainability in other words if we care
about human wellbeing over the long term
and at times I want to get to a
practical question I won't necessarily
have answers for this practical question
but you know if I were a policymaker or
a manager would the actions that I'm
taking with that increase or decrease
the probability of sustainable
development fundamentally I want metrics
and yardsticks that are going to be able
to answer that question and provide the
sort of practical advice now answering
that practical question requires that we
really have ways to measure impacts of
alternatives on current and future human
wellbeing and that can be complicated by
the following think about the following
logic suppose that I'm doing an action
which has an impact on an ecosystem
right so I drain a wetland to grow crops
what are all of the consequent changes
in the ecosystem that then occur because
of that change how does that affect the
set of ecosystem services that are
provided and how does this you know over
the longer term how does that affect the
set of services that are provided and so
you know and what are the values of
those and what is the impact on human
wellbeing so the chain here and
answering this practical question really
takes us from human actions through
impacts to ecological science or
hydrology or other Natural Sciences back
mapping back to ecosystem services which
are saying mapping back to human
wellbeing and start trying to figure out
you know are we better or worse off so
it's from my view it's really an
integrated question here for both
natural and social science to be able to
get at this question of are we improving
or we're moving further away from a
sustainable
development trajectory okay so I want to
talk first very briefly about some
operational metrics for sustainable
development so what should a metric
operational metric path where properties
that it should have then I'm going to
talk more length about the inclusive
wealth framework as a metric for
sustainable development I know you have
at least briefly talked about the work
by arrow and Partha disputa and car your
inhaler and others on efforts to measure
inclusive wealth and I'll touch on that
because it will be obvious in my
comments I think the really hard part
here is actually making things
operational to answer all those
practical questions so I think the
empirics here is much harder than the
theory but I'm going to lay out the
theory first and we'll get to the
appearance and then I'll talk about some
other approaches not at the national
level not along the lines of inclusive
wealth but sort of can we can we make
some progress say at local regional
scales they measure angel system
services and trying to incorporate those
or fold those into the set of economic
accounts and do a better job okay so
that's that's where I'm headed I thought
it was very interesting and putting up
all of the so pavan types I've stolen
your slide from the ones that you sent
me and the thing that I really liked
about this was you know we really want
to have any integrated measure economic
social environmental and the one that's
in the middle of all of those is is one
that you've labeled genuine savings
that's really what I'm calling inclusive
well alright so you can call genuine
wealth inclusive wealth and savings and
investment it's all about have we
provided enough savings and investments
so that the value of the capital but the
really inclusive or genuine value of the
capital is going up through time so
we're trying to integrate across
economic social and environmental in
order to do that so that's why I'm
really focusing on this inclusive wealth
framework okay let me pause here for a
moment I'm going to go into does
variable properties for a metric but let
me pause and see if there are any
questions at the moment and also just
just please turn it on what's up you
need to stop sharing the slide okay
sherry I can't see
and you probably
it's no
I can okay phonetic just go ahead okay
okay okay see I am a real person I'm not
just a disembodied voice okay hello
were there any questions you want
answered now or should we go back to
sharing the screen and go back to not
seeing each other where's your proof
about this assertion that this approach
will
by diversity couldn't we actually lose a
hell of a lot of diversity and have no
impact on well-being at all and in fact
possibly enhance it okay I'm actually a
survey that we necessarily if we just
focus on human wellbeing will
necessarily bring upon all the bio
capacity with us so that's why I put on
the kind of pervy so that you know you
might want to append this and say that
your objective is not purely or simply
human well-being over the longer term
but you might want an additional side
boards weren't may be additional main
objectives I am I will be agnostic on
that I will say one thing however which
is that we know that if you you know if
we do damage life-support system so if
we do fundamental changes to ecosystems
in ways that no longer provide a set of
ecosystem services that we in fact are
going to damage human wellbeing so and I
know you've done enough work on the U K
and T and other things that you know
what I'm talking about
but know there is a there is a question
I mean sometimes we might do things that
people say well I you know I want to
have more consumption goods in if that
means poor water quality and fewer
species if the people you know people
are willing to make that trade-off then
there is no guarantee I was being sort
of intentionally which is the long way
of having the natural science knowledge
to actually know when we hit that point
of reducing biodiversity in a way that
actually affects the life support
systems underpinning human wellbeing so
we just don't kind of know what to do
really
for ecosystem processes and functions
more directly rather than focus on
biodiversity and you know what's the
link between biodiversity and ecosystem
function so you know one can care about
species directly not necessarily for the
things that they provide in terms of
ecosystem services other than sort of
their existence value or cultural value
there's a huge amount of written in
ecology about the link between
biodiversity ecosystem services a lot of
it is inconclusive so basically I want
to go directly at this question of what
our ecosystem services and what what is
it that how do we take that link between
what ecosystems the ecosystem functions
and then the human wellbeing and that
link is ecosystem services and whether
one wants to go through biodiversity or
not you know I think there's a much more
direct link which is through services
okay should I go on
do I need to share screen again I guess
are you seeing okay okay all right I'm
we go I will give my screen going here
there we go okay do you want me I guess
I should try to X you guys out so that
it actually is a full screen okay see in
a bit okay so I wanted to talk very
briefly about so what do we mean what do
we want to have in a metric sustainable
development and that leads into the
discussion of inclusive wealth so
desirable properties if this is about
non declining human wellbeing then
really what we're talking about is
comparing the future with the present so
the first of the fundamental requirement
we have to have is that the metric has
to be able to address future well-being
not just a current snapshot of where we
are most approaches however if you look
at most indices I think you've probably
talked about the Human Development Index
or ecological footprint or a lot of
measures that are out there and I know
that Pavan talked about a number of
indices most of the indices are about
the current state that's fine it's good
especially if you look at past trends
but it doesn't tell you where we're
headed and the kinds of measures that
I'm really interested in are where are
we headed
is this forward-looking not nearly
backward looking the second one is that
it has to be operational in other words
we actually could measure this with
existing or potentially collectible data
and those to me are the two essential
things that we have to have in order to
really talk about a measure of
sustainable development for we're
looking and have it operational it will
also be very nice if it were
theoretically coherent and complete the
problem and and when I get to implicit
well we'll talk about that it does a
very good job I think on this sort of
third criteria and this theoretical
coherence and completeness it is
forward-looking the real question is
whether its operational or not and so
I'll get into that when I get to kind of
more of the
practical questions and measurement
questions okay for the most part I'm
going to be talking about sort of social
aggregates sort of in you know if you
thought about the average person or in
total how is you know all of society's
aggregate social wealth but before I do
that I want to make just a brief aside
on equity issues because clearly if
we're talking about aggregate measures
that doesn't tell us anything about how
particular segments of society are doing
so are we you know are the poor being
helped or hurt we can have aggregates
going up but the poor being worse off
and so a question that you might want to
ask is do we need to have disaggregated
measures report on the progress of
individuals or groups rather than just
this aggregate and in fact if you take
like the Brundtland Commission
definition of sustainable development
meeting the needs of the current
generation without sacrificing or you
know allowing the next generation
actually to meet their needs one way of
reading that is that it's all segments
of society have to be able to meet their
needs you know if particular parts of
society are being left behind that we
really have not that sustainable
development there are various approaches
that one could do this
most of them involve disaggregating so
that you actually are looking at
different groups not just the sum total
and you could look at you know the
percentage of the population that was
eating some basic threshold you know say
a $2 a day threshold or some measure of
Human Development Index you could if you
really wanted to focus a lot on equity
focus on the poorest so a rauzein
approach look at the welfare of the
worst off members of society most of the
discussion that I am going to talk about
one could modify the objective to take
account of equity concerns and I
actually think it's very important to do
so but for purposes of getting through
the talk clarity I'm I'm just going to
be talking about the
and that's where the literature is right
now but the equity point is very I think
is a vitally important question okay so
I now want to talk about inclusive
wealth as this metric of sustainable
development so I'm gonna plunge ahead
and go through I've been in the theory
and then when I get to the end of this
section I'll I'll pause again and sort
of take stock and see if there are
questions and then we'll go into more of
the empirical side okay so the advantage
of inclusive wealth as I've indicated is
that it provides a coherent and cohesive
view sort of unified coherent framework
to talk about sustainable development it
is forward-looking
I mean the wealth component it's really
focused on assets and asset value asset
values at least in theory are capturing
the future flow of benefits that those
assets create so that's why this is a
potentially useful approach for looking
at sustainable development the problem
here is that really to do this at the
moment it suffers from impossible data
demands so it's more of an ideal than a
practical guide to sustainable
development at the end of the talk I'll
come back and try to you know say how do
we bridge this and how do we make some
practical steps now even as we're
working towards this more ideal approach
okay so it's not the full answer to the
practical question but I think it
provides some guidance as to what kinds
of information we need and what we
should be what how we should be
collecting information or what we should
be doing okay so in inclusive well I
don't know the background of the people
in the class whether you're economists
or not economists I suspect there's a
mix of backgrounds the inclusive wealth
framework is fundamentally an economics
framework if you know growth theory or
you have macroeconomics any time and
you've gone through growth Theory
economic dynamics inclusive wealth is
essentially that's essentially what it
is
it is an extension in a practical sense
for what's in most economic textbooks in
the sense that it focuses on really
being inclusive well in other words
let's try to incorporate all forms of
assets including natural capital so not
just focused on manufactured capital or
manufactured capital human capital but
let's incorporate natural capital as
well okay so in order to do this I'm
going to take a very quick and highly
selective tour through economic theory
and there's really two components that I
need and I know you've already talked
about discounting you've had a session
on that so I'm not going to belabor that
but we do need to spend at least a
moment on well-being and what can we
mean by sort of non declining well-being
through time because that's the essence
of what the sustainable development
definition was about okay so if we talk
about well-being measure well-being
economists use the shorthand utility the
individual utility it's a subjective
view it's their view of satisfaction do
I like one thing more than another or am
I better off in state a or state B so
it's not the economists imposing their
view of utility it's what the individual
defines as their own well-being
okay so we can think about sort of the
state of the world or a social state so
anything out in the world that can
affect well-being of individual so we
could talk about so how well-off are
they given this sort of social State X
then that maps from the state of the
world to how well-off they are in that
state of the world so that can be
anything it could be you know how
polluted is in the world how much they
get to consume so forth the main point
about utility functions is that they
allow us to rank states of the world so
if they are better off at state X than Y
you know we just write that their
utility is higher for first aid X to
stay Y okay utility functions are quite
broad all I've really said is that this
is a way a way it's a shorthand for
capturing the preferences for the person
that basically
they could rank when they're better off
and worse off okay as I said it's
anything can go into a utility function
so it could be existence of biodiversity
it could be the aesthetic beauty of
their neighborhood it could be a food
consumption whether they have a
flat-screen television on and on and on
okay whether society is equitable they
care about that and so on okay so the
real point here the real work has to be
done in terms of dynamics right so we
need to think about how is welfare
changing through time and is this person
if we ask them tomorrow are they going
to say yep I feel more satisfied or I'm
better off in the future you know
tomorrow than they are than they would
have answered today so you need to think
about non declining utility through time
we want to evaluate that trajectory of
utility through time so if you've
already talked about discounting the
standard approach here is to try to
aggregate up this welfare well-being
through time and to collapse it back to
a single value called the present value
right so we're gonna take the whole
stream of benefits through time say how
well-off are you or how likely are you
to be this degree of well-off yes in the
future and how do we rank that relative
to how well you're well-off you are
today okay so if I now define things
explicitly in terms of time so we have
the state of the world at time T the
utility an individual at that time given
that state we talk about the discount
rate of discount factor so we can then
define the present value of the flow of
utility through time as this V function
right so this is the value of the stream
of utility through time okay and non
declining human wellbeing at least for
this individual is that this value this
present value so if I valuated it today
and I evaluated this tomorrow that your
feed function evaluated tomorrow is at
least as well as at least as good as
what it
today okay so the nice thing about this
is that it provides a very clear simple
definition of what it means to be on a
sustainable development trajectory okay
so but what does it really mean it
doesn't always mean that it well okay
what it means is that future prospects
or was not declining so the stream of
future welfare is at least as well off
as it if you define it in the future as
if you defined it today but that doesn't
mean that utility at any given instant
is always non declining just give you a
simple example of this so suppose that I
with my my utility meter whatever that
is you know registers to today one next
year and then three forever afterwards
and suppose I have a discount factor of
0.9 then if I sum up my present value of
utility across all of these years I do
that today I get a score of two point
seven two if I start this tomorrow
so next time period so you see I dropped
the two one becomes the first time
period and then I discount the threes on
out into the future if I sum that up my
present value is two point eight so even
though there was a dip in my utility
what 4 to 9 to 1 and then up to 3 I'm
still having this this oil value of
utility is non declining through time
and that's what that's what this
criterion is about okay so my offset of
decline utility and this you know into
the period two is offset by speeding up
all of those higher utilities off into
the further future okay the other thing
that this criteria does not necessarily
apply is that even though you satisfy
for some period of time it may not be
satisfied for all periods of time so
again I give you an example of this to
suppose that i rapidly ramp up my
utility so it goes from 1 up to 5 up to
10 and then
back down to five if I evaluate this
today I get a score of roughly 50 if I
evaluate it tomorrow I get a score of 50
4.5 I valuated two periods hence when
the town is present value or you know
the current period I go up to 55 but
then after that it goes down
I would not claim that this is in fact a
sustainable development path because
utility would be declining at some point
in the future so all of the periods of
e3 on are are less than v2 in fact less
than any of the v-0 v1 or v2 I hope this
is clear sort of what the mechanics of
this V function is doing or the present
value of the flows of utility because
that's really at the heart of this
inclusive wealth framework okay the
other thing is not only we aggregating
across time periods so the flow of
benefits through time but we're
aggregating typically up to the societal
level from the individual level so
typically that means we've got to
grenade up across many individuals or
many groups there's this fiction called
a social welfare function which is some
function of the utilities of all of the
individuals who make up Society I'm not
going to go into a lot of people who
have written about what are the
properties of a Social Welfare function
and does it exist an arrow has famously
about it doesn't exist under some very
basic kinds of conditions all I'm going
to insist on here is that this function
of social welfare function be increasing
in its arguments so if I make one person
better off then and nobody else worse
off that the social welfare function
increases other than that I'm not going
to really pin down what this aggregate
social welfare function really is about
okay let me get back to the main thread
of the story which is the sustainable
development and how inclusive wealth is
a measure
of sustainable development okay the
problem here is utility meters or
functions we can't measure this directly
right so we don't know really you know I
can't go out and directly measure V as
the present value of utility because I
can't measure individuals utilities much
less aggregate them up across people so
instead of going that approach of
looking at the flow benefits of utility
through time let's switch to using this
wealth measure which is a stock variable
so we'll look at the assets which are
stocks rather than the flows of utility
and so this you know what we're looking
at them is the capital asset so that may
be natural capital or manufacturer
capital will measure those a period of
time we're not going to be looking at
flows of services so but in principle as
I said the capital assets they can
they're the value of those capital
assets is really the present value of
the flow of the goods and services that
that capital asset generates it's labs
the link between what I just talked
about in the next couple of slides that
come up
okay so just forms of capital that we're
going to be concerned about well clearly
manufactured capital plant and equipment
infrastructure that contribute to
production and consumption but we're
also considering natural capital so
ecosystem States of processes biological
stocks biodiversity physical natural
resources so oil and mineral stocks all
of these contribute to human well-being
potentially contribute to human
well-being human capital the stock of
knowledge and experience the learning
kind of collective learning of society
and then another form of capital which
is a little bit elusive and hard to
measure probably even harder to measure
the natural capital the set of
institutions and relationships that
contribute to production I'm going to
probably for the most of the rest of the
talk really
focus on kind of the human manufactured
and natural but clearly social capital
is also vitally important you just look
at some countries that are resource rich
even human capital rich but are poor in
terms of how well-off they are in social
and economic terms largely because they
don't have a set of functional
institutions okay to get at the question
of sustainable development we need to
talk about savings and investment okay
so how much do we can see now versus how
much are we saving for future well-being
okay I think you all know about savings
and investment decisions in principle I
just want to state that what I mean by
savings and investment what I mean by
consumption is really broadly
interpreted here so consumption might be
looking at a pretty view or you know the
aesthetics of a situation but I
certainly could invest in that I could I
can make sure that I've maintained
vistas so that future generations will
also have the benefit of looking at
these beautiful views okay so saving and
investment again broadly interpreted is
anything that affects the evolution of
these capital stocks Fiat natural
capital social manufacturer human okay
so we can talk about this vector of
goods and services these consumption
goods if you will the utility that we
get from consumption and the vector of
capital stocks again including all four
varieties or anything that we think of
as a stock or an asset that affects
human wellbeing we're going to talk
about the evolution of those capital
stocks so they changed through time that
that will affect not only the stocks
themselves but basically the you know
our well being through time so what can
we consume again broadly speaking
through time so if we talk about the
change in the capital stock formally
that's just the derivative of the
capital stock with respect to time okay
and that's going to be a function of our
savings and investment decision which is
a
you know how much we consume versus how
much we say and it also can be a
function of the current capital stocks
and might have depreciation of current
capital stocks okay so we can formally
write down the optimal consumption or
optimal savings and investment choice is
the following we want to maximize the
flow of utility three times and it's
going to be a function of the capital
it's available at that time and so we
have to take this you know the evolution
of the capital stock which I just talked
about so if we solve out from kind of
the optimal consumption we get the
optimal capital stock and we plug in
that values we'll get this score for B
will tell will basically say what's this
value the present value of the flow of
utility through time its own bath - that
V function but note and I'm not actually
not going to go through the derivation
of this I'd be happy to do so but but
I'm sure you don't want me to do so
right now anyway but you know we can go
through and kind of you know what how
this unfolds of what the necessary
conditions are and the sufficient
conditions and so forth but the bottom
line of this is that when we solve out
for this B you know we solve that
problem we're going to get a value which
is a which is a function of how much
it's a function of the vector of capital
assets that we have okay so the more
capital assets that we have in general
that will allow greater flow of utility
through time and give us a higher
present value score through this B okay
so again if we want to come back to
sustainable development we want to be to
be non declining just some simple man up
if we take that optimization problem
where I get the V as a function of
capital stock I take the derivative
through time I get these two terms first
is how does V change as an individual
component of capital changes this KJ and
then how is that capital stock evolving
through time and because this is
inclusive wealth I have to sum this up
over all the capital stocks
okay so J 1 to n now the nice part about
this is it breaks this interest like to
May
Chung's what do I need to know I need to
know first of all what the value of any
given capital stock is so this is called
the shadow price for a capital you know
for capital asset J how if I change that
capital stock how that affects the
present value well being this V function
that's the that's the shadow price of
the capital asset now in some cases we
actually observe prices and so it's not
a shadow price it's actually an actual
price right but in other cases
especially with natural capital we'll
have to infer what that value is and
that's why the term shadow price is
there the second thing we need to know
about is the net investment of capital
okay so how is capital changing through
time so this e ka DT and that's the net
investment in capital asset J so if we
knew the shadow price you know the value
of a unit of capital we know how the
capital is changing this eye then what
we can do is we can sum this all up and
we get this term so that the change in
inclusive wealth or change in genuine
savings plus a it that's equal to DB DT
right this is our our sustainable
development criterion so if we want to
have sustainable development really what
we're requiring is genuine savings to be
positive
ie inclusive wealth to be non declining
through time okay so this is the the
theory part they say it's it's it's
fairly straightforward it's an
application of economic dynamics and as
a as theory it's it's a really nice
piece of theory it tells us kind of what
we should be focused on we should be
focused on you know how valuable various
components of capital are and how are
those changing through time okay so I
think I've just restated that on this
slide let me just go ahead and make sure
that I've sort of said all of this yeah
so here's the summary that the change in
inclusive wealth is really the change
and how how human wellbeing is changing
through time that trajectory and so
these are one and the one in the same
okay let me pause here because next I'm
going to go into a lot of the empirics
you know how practical is this what can
we measure and not measure so I will go
back to sharing the screen and see if
there is any any questions that you have
you want to
so I'll try to unpack a little bit here
so you know this when I was a graduate
student it was sort of before the
behavioral economics revolution and I
always stuck frankly to the supply side
of the economy because I didn't trust
the demand side of the economy and all
this stuff about utility functions and
it's like I don't know anybody who
behaves like the classical economic
theory utility function so I really I'm
so glad that the behavioral economics
world has come in and we actually talked
about real people rather than idealized
maximizers of something but okay so I I
can take your question a lot of
different way so let me let me start
with kind of the most basic which is I
think really the way to understand this
is if if we thought about this as you
know what are important constituents of
human wellbeing so we all know that we
need enough food to eat and we need
places to live and you know health is an
important component what I take is that
this is really at a fundamental level
trying to ensure that the constituents
of a good life are being provided both
now and into the future
so you know do I spend my money on
going to a movie or flat-screen
television I don't think we're ever
going to get to that level of you know
at this aggregate level I I don't think
we're I don't think it's well suited to
answering those kinds of questions what
I do think it's well suited to is asking
it that are we providing the fundamental
life support and so are we are we likely
to be able to produce enough food for
people in 2050 given that we've got
we're gonna have 9 to 10 billion people
and and are we you know other measures
of like health in the future our
resource is going to be adequate or as
the education system going to be up to
you know up to more better than what we
have now so I think there's a way of
thinking about this is about the kind of
basic components of human wellbeing and
trying to translate from what do we know
about the trends and serve fairly
fundamental assets how that train what's
the translation from providing education
and health to human wellbeing so I think
we're at that you know kind of mostly of
that scale that there is an interesting
component when you raise about
behavioral economics which is the
following
I'm suppose that and I I really do think
that we are largely creatures of our
experience so what we care about you
know in the next time period is heavily
conditioned on what we've experienced up
until now so you know most of you
probably would not consider living
through a Minnesota winter I've
experienced them and I've lived through
them and I don't think they're so bad so
you know I think I think our future
preferences in a way our action our
actions in the past
fundamentally conditioned our current
preferences and our current and past
actions will condition our future
preferences you know I actually think
that's that there's an interesting
perhaps I don't know if it's if it's a
good thing or a bad thing but I
you know people get used to what they
have and so in a way it makes things
more sustainable if you've never known
anything else than what you currently
you know have it may have been very
different or they have been better in
the past but that's not your frame of
reference and so you know it may be that
people in the future with diminished
biodiversity or diminished ecosystem
function as long as they have good to
eat and a place to stay they they might
say okay well you know we're happening
to this I mean you know we certainly
have much less in the way of natural
habitat now that people had in 1700 yeah
I doubt very many of us right now would
change what you are positioned for for
what people had in 1700 um so I you know
I think there's some really interesting
questions here about what do we mean by
aggregating a present and future
well-being and you know if if future
well-being is really conditioned on
current choices I think there's some
interesting puzzles that need to be
worked out in terms of this inclusive
wealth framework or ignoring generally
thinking about sustainable development
issues
that's good yeah
okay so I think I need to skip ahead now
okay so I want to shift gears and now
get practical we've talked about theory
at least at the 50,000 foot level the
question is can we measure changes in
capital assets or shadow values okay so
imagine a challenge can we put the
inclusive inclusive well can we measure
changes in the relevant stocks can we
measure the relevant shadow prices I'm
going to go through this actually very
quickly because I want to make sure I
get to the end of the talk which is
where I I get to other measures besides
kind of the arrow at all tight measure
of inclusive well okay what capital
stock should be included well this is
inclusive well so anything that affects
well-being should be included so all
forms of capital manufactured capital
well you know this is a typical form of
capital considered by economists this is
most closely related to things which are
in at least capital accounts today so we
have measures at least of some forms of
capital you know do we measure
depreciation accurately do we actually
have all four as of an effect I mean
there's a number of caveats here but for
the most part we have better measures of
manufactured capital than we are for
other measures of capital what about
natural capital so financial capital I'm
going to include land land resources
natural resources in the way of mineral
or energy timber fish stocks so forth
environmental quality but also ecosystem
processes that you know if we if we
change the ecosystem structure or
function that and led to changes in
these more proximate forms of natural
capital like Environmental Quality so
fundamentally we have to keep track of
kind of big infrastructure of ecosystems
just as we would keep track of the
infrastructure of manufactured
Capital on the human side okay
unfortunately natural capital we you
know we can certainly track certain
aspects of natural capital so mineral
resources energy resources timber some
forms of environmental qualities of
greenhouse gas concentrations but even
here of course what we want is not the
flow of minerals and energy we really
want how is the stock of these resources
changing so I don't want to know about
current oil production as much as I want
to know about reserves of oil and
there's great uncertainty about reserves
even for things like oil which are
heavily studied fish stocks you know we
have some stock assessments there are
questions about you know how accurate
and so forth but so we can measure some
stocks with uncertainty but we can
measure some stocks of natural capital
ecological processes some types of
environmental quality the resilience of
systems so if we if we are changing
systems is perhaps some ways that might
lead to in the future fundamental shifts
and how those ecosystems function we
would try to measure that and capture
that I think that's something right now
that we are woefully inadequate to be
able to do so there's a lack of
systematic data collection there's also
frankly a lack of kind of Gihon alluded
to it very early on when he said you
know what's our natural science based
understanding is it up to the task in
some some of these things it's it's
clearly not up to the task at the moment
okay so going on human capital so we're
talking about education experience you
know we can at least measure how many
hours you spent in the classroom whether
that actually measures how much you know
is as a harder thing and experience it's
also hard to measure health capital
actually turns out to be if you've read
the arrow article or looked at that the
2010 version their health capital
measures are hugely important
drive much more quantitatively important
than other forms of capital so the
changes that they look at in terms of
inclusive wealth are are really driven
by health capital considerations how
should we treat social capital
institutions there are some measures of
good governance can we predict in the
future how much good government's
there's there will be I think the answer
to there is we fundamentally know who
predicted the Arab Spring prior to the
beginning of this year how do we think
about trust relationships among people
and so on so there's a there's a lot in
social capital I think it's very
difficult to measure okay so in summary
there's many forms of capital some of
which can be measured some of which can
be measured but maybe only and precisely
in some isn't going to be very difficult
to get any kind of consistent data to
measure them at all okay turning to the
second component shadow values the ideal
world of economic textbooks is that we
have complete and competitive markets
for information
no externalities of public goods in
which case all capital stocks would have
market prices and market prices would
actually fully reflect the value the
contribution of that capital stock to
human wellbeing of course we live far
from a perfect world and so market
prices in general here's the statement
market prices if if you accurately price
capital stocks that should represent the
value of the capital stock in terms of
the present value of the flow benefits
created by that asset in the real world
we have incomplete markets for most
natural capital social capital even for
human capital we don't have market
prices for these things even for prices
that we do have of course there are
imperfections so we have monopolies we
have imperfect information or
externalities so that prices are going
to have a distorted signal of the
relative value certainly those people
who do environmental economics know this
well people who have done tea or other
things I mean this is this is the
classic problem
so you know I could go out there and
look at market price of coal that that
market price of coal does not reflect
the contribution of coal to greenhouse
gas emissions or mercury emissions or
air pollution or water pollution or
mountaintop mining the list goes on so
in order to correct the problem we
really have to know how does coal
burning change the stock those
environmental natural capital elements
so it contributes to greenhouse gas as
well ok what's the change in the
greenhouse gases we can probably do that
what's the value of the change in the
stock of greenhouse gas you know carbon
in the atmosphere in order to do that
we'd have to have a shadow value on or
social value of carbon that question
okay let me skip this slide in the
interest of time it was just talking
about examples of market distortions of
the fact that you have to worry about
prices coming out of those but as I say
in the interest of time let's let's go
on actually this is where I used to live
in Oregon so some people always ask well
can we really value all of these
intangibles and aesthetics
you know ecosystem services or
environmental quality I always pause to
try to get a little humility what what
would the value of this view worth what
would I be willing to give up in order
to preserve this these are tough
questions as as the you know the
question in the last break alluded to ok
one thing that I do want to mention is
that most of the work that is done in
environmental economics in terms of non
market valuation is that we're typically
measuring values under current
conditions right what we really want
here in terms of the shadow values of
these capital assets is to understand
the contribution of the stock to present
and future well-being so we really want
to have a dynamic view to non market
valuation for in general to these shadow
prices not just looking at what do
people or how do people value it today
ok so I wanna
the other thing I want to at least make
sure that I mentioned here is that the
value of the capital stocks the
treatment of uncertainty and this is
crucial because of course I've been
talking about the future what's the
present value of the flow of services
through time future conditions are
uncertain so how do we treat all of this
well in principle one would want to do
sort of a decision tree or you know
analysis where you specified all the
future potential conditions the
probabilities of those conditions
estimate the values under each of those
potential future States and find the
expected value or if you wanted to take
a more risk-averse approach you could
you know waited by by some risks notion
but basically you know find the expected
utility through time weighted by the
probabilities in practice of course you
know think about something like climate
change we just don't know what's going
to happen off into the future so it's
going to be very difficult to you know
specify all of the conditions or the
probabilities were the values of what
those happens in future states so you
know we're gonna have to back off of a
little bit on this sort of valuation and
really think carefully about what
potentially could happen in the future
what are potential risks how well-off or
bad off would we be whether those are
those conditions I'm going to again in
the interest of time gonna skip through
this in the slides which I could share
with you or make sure proverb has the
questions of doing this with climate
change in social cost of carbon would be
the shadow value of a unit of carbon in
the atmosphere or in the ground
somewhere this is a really hard problem
there's a lot of things and folks at
Yale have contributed to this certainly
a bill Nordhaus and Mendelssohn I've
talked a lot about this so go talk to
them
I'd be happy to feel questions on it but
interest of time I think
so where are we in terms of these
measurement issues so we're currently
very far from having accurate or
complete measures of all capital stocks
were very far from having measures of
the shadow values we certainly can do
partial analyses and the arrow and all
paper has done some and you know we can
kind of see where they are on this but
we're far from complete complete notions
or complete ability to measure this
theory of inclusive wealth so let me
pause here now and begin take some
questions and then I'll hopefully have
just a bit of time to plunge in on the
last step on sort of other
okay
okay be there I can't see you anymore
I'm pleased to see me okay you are
how much does
okay so I'll talk about the two then I'm
going to get to which it's arrows
prepped and and then our proton
ecosystem services we don't do it
speaking for me we don't do a good job
ecosystem services probe talking about
changes in total factor productivity
technology changes that's something that
I hope improve on arrow in all X do
reasonably good job of taking account of
total factor and incorporating that into
the analysis so you know with when they
go through their adjustments they start
kind of you know sort of the basic with
change in inclusive wealth but then they
adjust this population to get yep and
they also adjust this by increases in
total factor productivity it's what they
call vino
per capita change in inclusive wealth so
I'd say that they attempt to to
incorporate changes in productivity
most of the ecosystem services world is
a more basic issues and does not do a
good job of incorporating changes in
public life factor productivity
okay back to the slides okay all right
okay so I think you've talked about the
arrow at all paper there's a working
paper that they've done really trying to
measure inclusive wealth this is a
extension of the paper 2004 are we
consuming too much
bonds already talked about this so
hopefully I could go through this fairly
quickly I do want to just mention the
following though so they're measures of
natural capital include energy and
mineral resources timber timber
resources in carbon that's it okay so
you know it's a step in the right
direction
but from my perspective it so it's a
very partial step so there's no
ecological processes there's no notions
of resilience or you know how we're bust
the sisters are and there's very few
other ecosystem services so we're not
talking about air pollution or air
quality water quality aesthetics hunting
fishing I mean you know its energy its
minerals and it's timber and carbon
other than carbon all of these actually
higher traded commodities so it's it's
nice to look at the you know the prices
we can shadow values or just the market
prices although again one would want to
worry about the fact that particularly
for energy resources those are really
tied to changes they fundamentally
impact on the environment so we really
want to take account of their
environmental impacts they do that for
carbon but not for other measures this
is probably too small for you to read in
fact it's too small for me to read
unless they put on my glasses here and
I'm right on top of the screen but this
was just to know kind of what was
included in their in their measures of
natural capital
so you can see or hopefully you can see
it's oil natural gas got the energy side
they have various minerals bauxite
copper iron gold lead so forth and then
they have timber and there's a value in
here for lamb but it's not changing
through time so that's not going to
affect anything on there inclusive
wealth measures okay so the point here
so I just put this up for the US in for
China what's interesting is of course
oil and natural gas are resources that
are exhaustible and therefore as you use
them up those values are going to go
down timber is a renewable resource and
in fact has increased the timber
resources have increased in both the US
and in China and the value of those at
least in the u.s. is more than offset
the decline in value from the minerals
and from oil and natural gas okay so now
here's where we get to pulling together
the estimates of natural capital human
capital manufacture capital which
they're calling reproducible capital
here so looking at and also the changes
in carbon emissions so they're getting
to what is overall the change in the
capital stock in the US and in China
over the time period 1995 to 2000 okay
so this is I'm not going through kind of
what they included in human capital and
manufacturer capital but it's perhaps
more comprehensive than a natural
capital which is not very comprehensive
but it's still an incomplete list
okay so Bob on this is really you know
your question a moment ago how come how
well do we do with actually thinking
about total factor productivity growth
so we get more outputs from inputs
through time through better technology
and better ways of doing things so when
we factor in so the left-hand column our
left-hand column is just the growth kind
of the the raw comprehensive raw
comprehensive or inclusive wealth growth
rate so how are these assets
it's changing through time we're going
to modify that by population growth so
we can get a per capita which is column
three we're going to further modify that
but I total factor productivity so we're
going to add that up to get to column
five and then what's really interesting
and I think you've probably looked at
this in the sessions previously so
comparing the per capita comprehensive
wealth growth rate accounting for TFB
growth with the per capita GDP growth
rate in every case what's interesting is
that this comprehensive wealth growth
rate is smaller than the per capita GDP
growth rate so you know there's Sun GDP
is not doing a full job of capturing the
measures of depletion of various assets
however there is a pretty high
correlation if you look at it between
the per capita GDP growth and the
inclusive wealth growth rate those
countries which are high in one are also
high on the other okay I'm gonna skip
this this was basically the point of
this was just to tell you that health
capital really mattered kind of dwarfed
the other things and in fact the natural
capital changes were fairly small okay I
think this exercise is extremely
informative but it's informative not
only sort of for what it tells us but
also what we cannot do so there's huge
data gaps it requires many assumptions
about the accuracy of data and so you
know what I think that this is the final
word or even close to the final word an
answer to whether we're achieving a
sustainable development trajectory I
would say no there's a lot of things
which are missing and there's a lot of
things which I think we take a lot more
further study before I had great
confidence in them so you know in
summary there's sort of the stark
contrast between the elegance of the
theory the limited ability that we have
to measure capital stocks changes in
capital stocks in the the shadow values
um I think it's informative too there's
a quote that I really liked from book by
Stiglitz and Sen and so to see miss
measuring our lives or basically looking
at how well does GDP do and what should
be we doing instead of GDP in order to
get an accurate metric or measure of
changes in well-being and basically what
this quote I won't read it because you
can read it hopefully for yourselves
that you know basically what what
they're saying is that you know can we
do this where is this sort of a bridge
too far this trying to summarize
everything into one number for
sustainability what GDP has played a
role for in kind of summarizing economic
performance and what they go on to say
is it really is overly ambitious that at
the present we really can't while it's
great in theory and don't get me wrong I
really appreciate the efforts that they
have done and I think it has increased
our understanding but to think that
we're going to get a practical measure
of inclusive wealth anytime in the near
future I think this is not right and
maybe we ought to be thinking about
augmenting our the things that we can
measure through kind of economic
accounts so take that expanded set of
accounts that arrow at all show but then
also separately track important measure
important physical biological measures
of how our ecosystem is changing how is
that likely to impact on provision of
ecosystem services that are important
through time so we don't come up with
just one measure but we're going to have
several measures and look at the trends
in those measures in order to be able to
say something a little bit more
comprehensive about our trajectory and
whether we're on a sustainable
development trajectory or not okay so
I hope I'm not abusing things by just
going for a few more minutes and let me
just tell you a little bit about some of
the work we've done I think you had
talked with Gretchen
daily before about the natural capital
project and so some of the work that
we've done is is really trying to take
up this sort of more pragmatic approach
that Stiglitz at all think about can we
come up with sets of physical indicators
as well as sets that we can measures
that we can plug right into kind of
measures of economic sustainability or
you know the economic accounts okay so
we look at measures of ecosystem
services and how those change through
time again this is work with the natural
capital project which is a partnership
between Stanford Minnesota HR
Conservancy and WWF in particular we use
this is freely available the invest
software integrated valuation of
ecosystem services and trade offs I want
to talk about just one paper in
particular so modeling multiple
ecosystem services at landscape scales
this is a paper that was in cry tears of
ecology and environment and a special
issue on ecosystem services in 2009 and
very briefly what we did here this paper
was we had we looked at alternative
scenarios for how the future might
unfold in the Willamette Basin and we
actually had from this group the
Willamette partnership a set of maps
which were scenarios of land use and
land cover for the Willamette Basin for
every decade from 1990 to 2050 and they
had these three different scenarios a
kind of business as usual one a
development oriented one of a
conservation oriented Ward we used
invest along with spatially explicit by
physical and economic data in order to
predict how under each of these
scenarios set of ecosystem services
would change through time this is a map
of the Willamette Basin in Oregon
western part of Oregon
these are just the maps for 1990 the
initial starting point and then
how these evolved through time so
there's an app actually for every decade
2000 2010 and so forth up to 2050 and
under these difference in areas so for
every time period beyond 1990 for every
decade we actually had a map for each of
the three scenarios we then used invest
to score given those land use land
covers how well we do for this variety
of ecosystem services you can see the
list of services that we tracked in this
model if we could do the model over
again today we actually have an expanded
set of services that we could track as
well as species conservation and this
gives you the the results so under the
three scenarios for each of the given
decades from 1990 up to 2050 how well
did we do for each of these various
metrics so the market value metric is
actually the value of agricultural
production timber production and housing
values which are easily we combined
those into a single measure which is
kind of the ones that are have market
values and can be combined a dollar
terms the other ones at least on this
chart we left in biophysical units of
the amount of carbon sequestered how
well did species do so this is a the
biodiversity is actually a proxy for
amount of habitat and how well did we
maintain species given how much habitat
there was flood control soil erosion and
water quality is phosphorus you'll note
that the conservation scenario does well
on five out of six unfortunately it does
not do well in terms of market value so
if you asked landowners which of these
scenarios would they prefer you know the
others are sort of public goods the
landowners themselves would do better
under planned transitory development but
you know suppose we actually could
internalize some of these or get
payments for some of these public goods
or internalize the externalities how do
you want to say it so the left-hand side
on the circles this is the trade-off
between the market the value marketed
goods on the horizontal axis and how
well did we do in terms of fight over
the conservation and the vertical axis
and this is just accounting for
agriculture timber and housing values
the triangles on the right also add in
the value of carbon sequestration so
suppose that we could take a calculation
for social cost of carbon in this paper
if I remember correctly was on the order
of $43 a ton see if we added those
values of carbon in now what do we get
is no longer this sort of trade-off but
in fact the conservation scenario does
better in terms of both the present
value if we incorporated that ecosystem
service of carbon sequestration along
with agriculture timber or residential
housing and so we now get this sort of
it does better both in terms of net
present value as well as species and and
that points out the you know I even if
we don't have inclusive wealth measures
that are complete and fully accurate I
still think we can do exercises like
this and inform decision makers that say
you know you really better up you know
we would be better off under this
conservation scenario with an under
development or plant trend if we really
took account of the full value of
ecosystem services and here I'm not even
taking account of the full values but
you know we added in water quality or
flood control then the conservation
scenario since it did better on those we
haven't even even larger lead than the
kind of narrow lead it has that present
value over the development of plant ran
scenarios okay so you know kind of in
summary on this the the failure to
incorporate these oftentimes leads us to
poor decisions
so exercises like what Ian did in the UK
and what teeb has done and what the
Millennium is ecosystem assessment has
done and now ongoing work natural
capital project and others you know can
we do a better job it's not going to do
a perfect job because we certainly can
but can we do a better job from where we
are now and I think the answer there is
clearly yes there's a lot of low-hanging
fruit we you know we basically don't do
hardly anything on this front now and so
you know there's a lot of room for
improvement let's put it that way we
even went out a complete accounting
we can certainly improve on
decision-making by incorporating what we
know who our predictions about likely
impacts on services in natural capital
and so I think I think this is just sort
of a summary slide and I think I could
probably I just want to get to the last
one which is you don't have a grand
unifying measure of sustainable
development
you know physics also doesn't have a
grand beautifying theory but physicists
still keep on their work and they still
make progress and I think we can make a
lot of progress in fact I think we can
make huge progress because we're
starting in a you know the way we're
starting from such a poor base that that
you know really fundamental advances can
be made relatively quickly we do have
enough measures and metrics you know
through efforts like what Pavan LED and
team ian is leading others I think we
can make a lot of progress and I
certainly wouldn't wait around for the
perfect approach you know let's let's
let's be practical let's get on with the
business here and trying to improve so
where we are now to incorporate
ecosystem services natural capital and
to really you know try to fulfill this
notion of the getting as close or closer
to this notion of inclusive wealth okay
so with that I probably abused my time
and let me stop and stop sharing the
slides and see if there are any
questions